mon premier voeu c'est que pour sortir
de la crise il a de lakovic 19
on affronte la réalité avec courage et
j'ajouterais sans se réfugier derrière
le principe de précaution mon deuxième
voeu concerne le moyen orient
j'espère qu'avec les accords d'abraham
et bientôt un accord nucléaire avec
l'iran
on va enfin pouvoir retrouver la paix
dans l'ensemble de cette région avec le
développement économique qui suivra pour
tout le monde
le mont troisième veut concerne la
culture parce qu'il faut qu'elle puisse
retrouver au plus vite sa place
traditionnelle dans notre société
loin de toute censure et je dirais aussi
de toute exclusion